I let's delve a little bit more deeply
showing into those events at HMP
Birmingham perhaps the the worst prison
riot that we've seen since Strangeways
back in the eighties let's speak to
Steve dagger I think he's a prison
consultant for former prisoner himself
and joins us from central London this
morning Steve thanks very much for being
with us
and I suppose the question that will be
on many people's minds this afternoon is
whether or not there is a sense of
inevitability about riots such as this
that when you bring together people who
have committed offenses deprive them of
their liberty and then further in the
run-up to Christmas at place that kind
of emotional pressure upon them is it
the case that we should simply expect to
see events such as this you know
periodically well no not really I think
it's unfair I think I think the reason
why we're seeing events that we are
recently here at Birmingham and recently
a previously at Bedford is because
prisoners are basically fed up of being
treated like animals and the situation
is now is that we have too too few
officers looking after too many
prisoners and too many prisoners with
too little to do and if you cage
prisoners like animals in these
Victorian prisons where two men to a
Cell which was designed for one and then
you unlock them and say immediately oh
sorry guys you've got to go back to your
cell I mean they're inevitably gonna
turn on us I look we've had enough
something has to we're rebelling you can
compound that with the Christmas period
obviously emotions are running very high
at Birmingham Prison is a category B
local prison which is probably one of
the most emotionally charged prisons
because it's where everyone starts their
prison sentence or they're on remand or
possibly starting very long sentences so
this this is foreseen this is something
that's caused in my opinion purely and
simply down to the the cuts that have
been brought about by previous
governments give us an idea of the scale
of the cuts that have taken place to the
Prison Service over the past few years I
mean speaking to the prison officers
Association yesterday evening they
flagged up the fact that you know 30 of
their members have resigned from their
posts at this one particular prison in
recent weeks and the conclusion that you
have to draw from that is that from
their perspective at the situation is
untenable well it's just not the 30 from
Birmingham in in honesty since 2010 when
this when the system was already
creaking I mean I was
there in 2010 so I can tell that from
personal experience since 2010 there are
7,000 prison officers who have been cut
from the system plus there's been cuts
to spending in rehabilitation project
projects and vocational training so
therefore there's little for prisoners
to do so the net result of that is that
prisoners are having to be confined to
their cells because there are not enough
officers on the wing to look after them
so there and they're confined to
incredibly squalid cell structures Plus
that the lack that the the reduction in
prison officers has brought about
increases in security risk there's more
drugs coming in there's more phones
coming in there's more SIM cards coming
in and and the net result of all that is
that it's absolute crisis and total
chaos in our prison system why is this
not being talked about more I mean you
don't have to doubt very deeply into
social media or indeed into the archives
to discover stories about deaths and
custody deaths in prison the amount of
mobile phones that are able to make
their way inside prison the amount of
drugs that are circulating mental health
problems amongst prisoners I mean the
list of problems with the Prison Service
is as long as my arm
but successive governments have done
nothing about it apparently well it's
not a vote winner is it really let's be
honest I mean every the former justice
secretaries and I remember Ken Clark I
think in 2010 2011 when he had some very
very good ideas on how to improve the
prison system he was shot down in flames
and replaced by Chris Grayling
who came in from the completely other
opposite end of the spectrum he decided
to cut cut just not the meat but cut
into the bone of the fabric of the
prison system so this has been spoken
about successively for years we've been
talking about it for at least two or
three years in our blogs and the prison
officers Association had been warned of
warning this the various charitable
groups have been warned in this we all
saw this coming so it shouldn't be a
surprise that we are having a situation
now where we're having riots where we're
having suicides you know there's a
suicide in there every two or three days
in prison and our reoffending rates are
somewhere really 50% I'm so sorry we are
going to have to stop that we really
appreciate you joining us here on Sky
News that not just
runner-up attained thanks very much
thank you